I'm getting such a feeling of like from
it like it's the last place I want to be
right now so when I was about I'd say
seven years old I went to a birthday
party and they had a bouncy house and
I'm bouncing around having a good time
like you do when you're a kid in a
bouncy house and then at some point I
was in a corner in that I I fell and
then someone near me fell and the added
weight started to weigh down the corner
of the bouncy house and I like remember
feeling some just this weight on my body
so I was about ten years old and we were
having a family party so my mom thought
it would be fun if she rented a bouncy
house so we decided that we were gonna
have some fun of the bouncy house before
anyone got there - my dad was leaf
blowing so he had headphones on to block
the sound from the leaf blower he
accidentally unplugged the bouncy house
while my mom and my brothers were inside
of it and then all of a sudden it
rapidly started deflating and so my mom
took charge and saved all of our lives
I was probably four years old big
birthday party for a classmate of mind
I'm sort of off in the corner so I kind
of bounced my way over there's a kid
with one of the balls from the ball pit
he's using the ball to wipe his ass
and so really ever since then I've been
a little bit traumatized and I
distinctly remember feeling like oh my
god life is real and there is pain in
the world and I'm experiencing it right
now like genuine terror and fear so ever
since then I've been quite fearful of
bouncy houses I mean I just think that
kids do disgusting things in these
things
[Music]
you know I'm not going into a bounce
house I'd like to face your fears you
know I'm sure I could handle it why do
you guys have a bounce house you do
there's a bouncy house here oh my god no
I can hear it I'm actually good about to
Delta house today hello old friend
I know this is do you think I'm getting
such a feeling of like from it like it's
the last place I want to be right
you think I can make it through there
it's not that I dislike bounce houses I
realizing that I think I might be afraid
of that you know it's not that upsetting
it's very bouncy but you know my head's
right here I got a giant head you can
put this in black and white dramatic
recreation I fell and then the next kid
fell on me and then they all piled on
and I was
crushed in such a way
I tell you three living my childhood
no I don't like it
yeah you see that maybe it has nothing
to do with the incident like maybe I
just deep down hate bounce houses I now
have to traumatic bounce house stories
you know I'm not afraid I acknowledge
that what happened was an accident when
I was a kid and I'm not you know there's
nothing to be afraid of
a good bit haha
but I can't believe this is that
[Applause]
[Music]